[Music]
all right welcome to Hannity tonight
marks the end of yet a major week of
accomplishments for the president and
the Trump administration two historic
new trade deals a record-setting economy
major progress on the border wall safety
security and prosperity for all
Americans nobody can dispute any of this
none of it matters to today's
radicalized democratic socialist party
today the president sums it up perfectly
during an event with college football
national championship
LSU take a look just tell the coach we
don't normally do this but I'm doing it
for this team anybody would like to come
with me to the Oval Office we'll take
pictures in the Oval it's a special
place we'll take pictures behind the
resolute desk it's been there a long
time a lot of presidents some good some
not so good but you got a good one now
even though they're trying to do a beach
the son of a [ __ ] can you believe that
[Applause]
Democrats know the president will be
vindicated at the end of the senate's
trial they don't care they are more
interested in finding an outlet for
their psychotic antitrump rage try and
bloody the president up so it hurts him
running in 2020 on Wednesday Nancy
Pelosi all smiles there she is literally
signing off on her BS partisan and
Pietschmann articles handing out
commemorative gold pens with her
autograph on them and taking well
pictures anybody who wanted them it was
her crowning and only achievement
basically is House Speaker that very
same day Democrats tried to derail the
Senate impeachment trial with a
last-minute smear campaign disguise as
important to evidence the exact same
tactic they used member against Brett
Kavanaugh did the same thing now by the
way the new evidence said that Joe and
hunter were innocent and that the
prosecutor that was investigating zero
experience Hunter was corrupt oh that's
the new evidence oh great glad they
determined all of that right before
their very eyes and that night the left
anointed a brand new Savior this is
Michael avenatti
2.0 a man out on bail charged with
felony campaign finance fraud and hiding
get this you can't make it up a million
dollar payment
the country of Russia like I said
avenatti 2.0 254 appearances for
avenatti in one year does like their
love affair with the currently
imprisoned attorney Democrats and the
mob willing to overlook massive
credibility issues run with it because
that guy yes who's being charged with
serious crimes let Partners feeds into
their anti-trump hysteria same people
who are lying to you then or lying to
you now same cast of characters will
break this down in detail coming up and
of course we're just beginning to
scratch the surface of this week's
jam-packed news cycle and yet somehow
fake news CNN they found time to spend
an entire day whining about Republican
senator Martha McSally
how dare she call one of their reporters
a liberal hack when they are liberal
hacks one idiot called it a chilling
attack mob in the media they're so
sensitive Democratic allies truly live
in this alternative reality but buckle
up because well if they get their way
well in the coming days will only get
worse in the days and weeks ahead they
want to drag this country through the
mud and now the president has a chance
to fight back finally he has now
assembled the legal team to represent
his case in the Senate including White
House Counsel Pat's at Bologna
well with the president's personal
attorney that would be Jay Sekulow
former independent counsel Ken Starr who
conducted the investigation that led to
the impeachment of former President Bill
Clinton Starr is joined by former
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi and
two other experienced lawyers we know
about robert ray and Jayne Raskin
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
will also play a vital role leading the
constitutional oral arguments against
impeachment the president's legal team
will easily destroy the Democrats -
bogus articles of impeachment because
this entire impeachment charade is
nothing but a political smear campaign
Democrats well they're gonna try and
drag the trial on for as long as humanly
possible they want to slow walk the sham
shift show and build the
sadena insanity so they'll have a major
crescendo crescendo conspiratorial drama
so they're gonna try to enter into
evidence well new things they're gonna
try and demand that new witnesses
testify they're gonna try and demand
that new investigations based on new
evidence magically turns up at the last
second be introduced from the guy that
is indicted you're gonna do anything and
everything to derail the president's
forthcoming acquittal but their Achilles
heel is none other than this guy
the real quid pro quo guy quid pro quo
Joe and of course his son zero
experience under Biden who made millions
and millions of millions from a corrupt
Ukrainian oil and gas company all while
his father was spearheading the Obama
administration's policy on Ukraine Vice
President Biden even leveraged a billion
of your tax dollars in order to get a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired son of a B he
did why did he want the prosecutor fired
he was investigating a zero experience
son what company would ever pay somebody
millions if they have zero experience
none any of you ever get that deal now
that is the very real corruption the
very core of this impeachment charade
Democrats you want to draw this out go
down this road now it becomes a very
dangerous game and the Senate is now
officially the new shift sham show and
by the way just like the rush of
collusion hoax and the Cavanaugh smear
and every other con job from the radical
left the Trump hating left we know how
this story will end complete vindication